gerade lieben um hier für mich
der name ist nur dann herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ich weiß dass der trend sich schon
jahre alt ist oder so aber wir haben
davon ein paar leute von euch den
kommentaren berichten und ich habe mir
gedacht ich gehe da einfach mal drauf
wie leute das machen weil ihr euch
fragen worum es geht und zwar geht es um
die kylie jenner lipp challenge im da
geht es darum dass leute sich zunächst
mal forums geht hierfür sollen die
challenge teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
eine tasse flasche oder ein schott glas
oberhalb der lippen ansetzen und circa
fünf minuten lang saugen sowie unter
druck erzeugt er dafür sorgt das blut in
die lippen fließt und sie anschwellen
lässt dieser fragwürdige weg zu xl
mister war mit schmerzen verbunden ein
mädchen schreibt auf instagram ein
ganzer mund bereich hat sich wieder
gefärbt und das tut unglaublich wie es
geht bei diesen trend also quasi darum
dass irgendwelche mädchen oder jungs
versuchen wieso machen das überhaupt
jungs alter die halten sich irgendwie in
schottland an den mund und erzeugen
dadurch unter druck und dann werden die
lippen auf einmal richtig groß und ich
hab mir ganz einfach mal eine
compilation wo so ein paar videos drin
vorhanden sind wo leute diese keine
illusionen gemacht haben zum ersten mal
und dann halt ihre reaktion darauf
zeigen
ich dachte halt wenigstens die schillers
ode sieht halt nur scheiße aus tarragona
visuellen es sieht einfach nur ab sich
aus gesagt so am ende monat wieder warum
tust du es überhaupt alter es sieht nur
scheiße aus sie lacht einfach so was ist
mit euch alter es spaß wenn ihr das
macht warum wundert er irgendwie europa
ausgehen so es ist doch klar dass die
irgendwie angeschwollen sind und dick
sind oder so
[Musik]
es liegen nur chance warum macht man so
war es sieben konnte ich mal guckt sie
euch an was in euch gefahren also
natürlich mischt euch zuschauer gefallen
ihr habt das denke ich alles noch nie
gemacht aber diese leute die wir uns
jetzt noch weiter angucken alte was ist
los mit euch mal
ich fasse euch das video mal kurz
zusammen
omega omega und komponist freundin was
laberst du man versteht dich nicht wir
schauen sie uns noch mal an und ich
versuche jetzt mal mit untertiteln zu
arbeiten und moralisch chronisch kranke
wenn du in das ist das hat sie definitiv
so gesagt du bist ein junge liga und
machst du das warum brauchen warum
brauchst du dicke lippen alter kylie
jenner kann gerne und vorbild für mädels
sein und mädels können es auch gern
ausprobieren so ist es kann mit case
kann eigentlich nicht klappen aber es
ist man sieht ja dass du scheiße
aussieht aber was stellt man sich vor
als junge denkst du du reist mehr weiter
auf wenn du so dicke lippen hast ja ich
verstehe es einfach nicht
bei dir hat nicht nur die lippen sondern
auch der richtige fender ich versuch's
mal wieder nachzustellen
im recall
humor und was willst du für ein mensch
der ja erst mal machst du total
bescheuert und dann fragst du ernsthaft
ob es uns gefällt ist die kuppel
bestimmte uns karriere kaminwerk gab die
garmin sagte kakas großem ärger okay sie
hat hier in ihrem video gesagt dass sie
am nächsten tag schule hat und kylie
jenner sie total fucked up gemacht hat
und keine jenner soll sich [ __ ] und so
ich weiß was kann keine gelder dafür
dass du das machst du sie ist bestimmt
nicht zu dir gegangen hat in dieses ding
vors maul gehalten
dieser macht das jetzt eine eigene
entscheidung gewesen also sie hat nicht
mehr den mund bewegt und konnte sprechen
ich mach's nach freunde
oh wow
seid ihr für münchen dk ich verstehe
euch einfach nicht was er hat so völlig
oder ware gemacht hast einfach raus
super weg so er ich hatte keine ahnung
was sie irgendwie passiert
wir halten schon mal fest die standard
reaktion wenn man kein genie challenge
macht es einfach immer zu sagen raum
egal jedes gezeigte video hier also
glaube ich auch magath in sich du lachst
wie ein affe ihr könnt mir ich nicht
sagen dass das noch schön aussieht ohne
schwarz nichts gegen die leute die hier
die videos gemacht haben so hab das ja
auch nur getestet und ich meinen ihr
habt euch ja selber dazu bereit erklärt
das ganze ins internet zu stellen und
aber älter so macht das doch bitte nicht
nochmal also wieso heißt aber kylie
jenner lebt scheint also das sieht
überhaupt nicht so aus wie ihre lippen
wie können menschen so komisch lachen
alles klar da haben wir wieder das auch
mal drin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay wenn ich es nicht gewusst hätte
dass es von der calle journalist hätte
ich auch sagen können dass das irgendwie
ein motor sound ist oder so ich packe
jetzt mal den zaun von diesem video
hinter das video von einem auto was
gerade den motor an machen
okay ich bin raus das was ihr vom video
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn es das getan hat last
auf jeden fall mal einen dicken daumen
hoch da die gesagt die challenge ist
schon ultra als also locker schon 12
jahre oder so aber wir haben die leute
gesagt luca google das mal reagiert
einmal drauf da gibts echt total
bescheuerte fell videos von jobs hat
euch irgendwie gefallen hier findet hier
einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf gehen könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren und hier findet ihr ein
musical action video eingeblendet da
habe ich auf musicals reagiert worden
sie können ja auf jeden fall bei dem
auschecken also kanal abonnieren
musikvideo und ich bin jetzt raus haben
übrigens die neue beleuchtung hier wie
findet ihr das gut oder chance